c'est une maladie qui touche une femme
sur dix je commençais à avoir vraiment
des des douleurs comme si en fait on
vous donne des coups de poignard dans le
dos le ventre des médicaments ne
fonctionnait plus j'avais extrêmement
mal et peur aussi dorée avoir un
prochain si comme on va s'évanouir à des
bouffées de chaleur en zombies quoi
oublier qu'ils souffrent les douleurs
dans la cuisse elle verrait ap
cette maladie c'est l'endométriose elle
porte son du fait de la présence d'un
tissu à l'intérieur du ventre la plupart
du temps qui est tout à fait comparable
à l'endomètre qui le dessus bien
l'intérieur de l'utérus
d'où son nom d'endométriose il n'y a pas
une maladie mais autant de maladies
qu'il y a deux femmes avec des symptômes
très multiples pour la société
l'endométriose est perçue comme une
maladie psychosomatique me donner du
coup du mur fait non on me disait que
c'était normal que voilà ce téméraire
on se dit tout le temps que c'est normal
d'avoir mal pendant ces règlements faite
par comme ça en tout cas
est-ce que vous avez vous déjà avec ses
idées reçues la prise en charge est plus
longue
charlotte a commencé à se plaindre de
douleurs importantes en novembre 2010
est elle se tourne vers plusieurs
spécialistes est un parcours du
combattant qui commence pour elle
à la suite d'un irm le diagnostic tombe
un an plus tard elle est atteinte
d'endométriose leterme fait un peu par
qui on connaît pas en fait moi on m'a
annoncé sa entre deux portes à la fin de
l'irm à paris c'est un coup de massue
après c'est un soulagement aussi de
savoir qu'on n'était pas folle est que
et que voilà il ya une vraie maladie qui
explique tous les symptômes qu'on peut
avoir
je rentre dans les détails
est-ce que c'est au début du rapport ou
se continue au fond l'endométriose est
une maladie qui joue sur la vie intime
des patientes puisqu'elle ressentent des
douleurs pendant les rapports sexuels
j'ai commencé à ressentir d'extrême
douleur lors de mes rapports sexuels je
vais seigner énormément et je comprenais
pas trop ce qui m'arrivait il existe des
moyens pour soulager la douleur mais
aucun traitement spécifique n'existe
pour l'instant certaines patientes se
tourne alors vers la médecine douce
valérie barthélémy est spécialisé dans
la rééducation périnéale
depuis quatre ans on a avec nous un
matériel assez performant qui nous
permet par électrostimulation de pouvoir
soulager le patient directement en un
travail final et il ya aussi une grosse
part de discussion l'écoutent et la
parole sont primordiales pour ses
patientes atteintes d'endométriose qui
se sentent souvent seuls face à ce
manque de prise en charge
c'est déjà une maladie qui est compliqué
qui est dur psychologiquement
physiquement et on se retrouve tout seul
en fait autre souffrance pour ces femmes
l'endométriose est la première cause
d'infertilité non infectieuses en france
aujourd'hui
j'ai appris que j'avais un
vieillissement accéléré et que du coup
je dois congelés mais aux vues voilà à
ses défis ses quatre enfants avec des
premières douleurs à 10 ans et demi mais
diagnostiqué à 19 ans audrey vient de
subir sa troisième opération
vous aviez une très belle on ne les
trieuses là où il y avait de la teinte
là en tout cas visible on a tout enlevé
ne pas perdre espoir même lorsqu'on est
atteinte d'endométriose à 28 ans audrey
a réussi à concevoir un bébé par
fécondation in vitro puis un deuxième
par voie naturelle deux enfants en et en
attendant de maîtrise
j'ai eu par miracle une petite piscine
qui s'est installé est en outre en moi
j'ai appris que j'étais enceinte donc
une marche mondiale est organisée par
rando france ce samedi le départ est
fixé à 15 heures sur le parvis de la
mairie du 15e arrondissement de paris